hello everyone and welcome to another
game from round nine of the 2018 single
Cup as we already said we are going to
show that when our known versus
Alexander Luke and the beautiful
sacrifice on f7 but before we check that
out I would just like to say that the
first thing you will see in the
description below is a link to st.
Louis's Chess Club last video they're
alive
the the video from the live stream
yesterday and I really really would
invite you to switch all of your
dislikes into likes as it is it's really
not cool for a chess video to be
swimming in so many dislikes I have
already stated this in every of my
social media but I would also like you
to know invite you to do it here so
hopefully you will follow this advice
that being said let's check out this
game now like we said Aragon vs Greece
chop onion has the white pieces and he
also would very much enjoy winning this
game the ketchup the Fabi d4 was played
by Onion Knight to f6 Knight to f3 and
d6 g3 and Knight B to d7 Bishop to g2
and E 5 now c4 c6 Knight to c3 and here
arjan is basically inviting leadership
to push efore and if you're if you
enjoyed positions like these you will
definitely push efore and I mean why not
in grabbing grabbing more spaces
something everyone strives to do
capturing and before would simply I felt
the whites developed pieces central I
centralized his Queen so not something
you want to do here efore was played and
now comes Knight to h4 as you you will
most likely notice this in pretty much
every one of eleven rn's games he really
really really loves the h4 square he
always either pushes h4 or as you can
see in this game puts his nice on this
nice h4 square and it's very it's very
enjoyable how he takes advantage of this
now Grisha pushes the five we have
castles by Aragon and Bishop the b4c
captures on d5 see captors on d5 and now
f3 White has the challenge black center
here and of course white
very much enjoys blackwood capture here
but be assured captures and c3 is played
first will be captures on c3 and now we
have castles so what do you do here now
it's very interesting how Oregon makes
use of his undeveloped bishop on a3 and
combines it with his funny knight on h4
and this is something our own y'know
will often say in his interviews one of
the reasons why well I wanted to use
another quote but it was simply too big
but it's something I learned and says
that he enjoys playing chess 960 very
much in that he enjoys the bughouse very
much because playing such versions of
chess where you don't simply strive to
create familiar chess positions but
rather you want to create something can
come very very handy in playing you know
normal chess games so here he plays
Bishop to e3 which tempo attacking
griffix Rokon e8 we have rook to e8 and
now comes nice - f5 so already his
bishop on c1 and the night and h4 became
a knight on f5 that is ready to jump
over to d6 we have nights to be six
opening up an attack to this Knight and
here comes Knight to d6 and now a very
bold move by Grisha grips rook is under
attack here on e8 but he goes Knight to
c4 he invites Aragon to capture the
exchange here rook captures any eight
and after Queen captures Bishop to c1 as
your Bishop is under attack here now
comes a three the night is very firmly
placed on c4 there is no B pawn or D
pawn that there is a deep one but not
one that can challenge the knight on c4
and it's a beautiful position for this
knight or a beautiful square and the
knight really firmly protects the pawn
on e3 the pond and III really stifles
the whites development and although the
engine likes this position for white no
human would play this in their right
mind
maybe maybe cousin would but very hard
to imagine this as you know you would
spend so much time trying to figure out
what to do here and it's it's simply not
not worth it especially for Aragon who
you know appreciates development above
all and activity
okay Knight c4 Knight captures on c4 D
cap
Chauncy for and now f capture sunny for
here instead of going for material
Aragon has now a semi-open F file and
well if you've seen the game by now you
know that he will use it Knight captures
on e4 and now Queen to c2 with a double
attack against d4 Knight we have Queen
to d5 and it seems like a very nice move
here if you continue piling up on the
night that is pinned here for example
rook F or you will this will be met with
Bishop to a5 after y2 doubles up here
Bishop d6 will be played still keeping
an eye on the knight also adding more
protection to the f7 pawn but as black
would be pretty much okay here Aragon
has a different plan as this has only
moved 17 Grisha was already extremely
low on time he still has to make more
than 20 moves and to reach time control
and he was a very very low on the clock
so Aragon goes for a different approach
he plays rook captures on f7 and now
what do you play here well you could
play Queen captures on f7 but if Queen
captures then Bishop captures on e4 okay
you're up the exchange but your pieces
are undeveloped Bishop captures on h7 is
coming if you if you put the pond and
Bushell comes to g6 you will win back
the exchange and keep a better position
and if you simply try to give the h7
pawn away and develop your pieces then
after captures and King h8 Bishop to b4
white will definitely have what will
have compensation for for the exchange
but in time trouble although this might
have been the best course of action for
Luke he instead goes for King captures
on f4 on f7 which is which is a stronger
reply but you know getting your king out
in the open and allowing Levin Aragon an
attack while you are in severe time
pressure not not perhaps the greatest
idea but ok look to f1 check and now we
see the problem if you play King to g8
you get Bishop captures on e4 and now
you don't have the luxury of recapturing
if Queen captures Queen captures and now
of course you cannot capture the Queen
because the bishop from a3 is guarding
f8 rook to f8 that this will be
checkmate
so after loop to f1 check Bishop to a5
strongest move
and then out comes g-force simply
attacking the pinned piece g6 and now
Queen to see one here Aragon is
threatening Queen to h6 to try and
infiltrate English ships position and
what would a move like rook to e6 hard
hard move to find in time trouble
definitely you have to see that you can
actually allow Queen to h6 and now after
King to g8 and the gtas an f5 now with
the G captures an f5 this comes with an
attack against Arvind and Queen after
the Queen moves route comes to f6 the f1
is protected twice the other row can
come into the game all would be well
here for black but you know such
variations are extremely hard to find
under under severe time pressure here a
gray should immediately prevented Queen
to h6 would King to g7 but now comes
pawn captures on f5 GTRs on f5 and now
Bishop captures on e 4f captures on e4
ends now Queen to f4 our ideas of Queen
to f6 check and so on and so on
first h6 was played here Queen to c7 by
Oregon with check King h8 and now comes
Bishop to d6 preparing Bishop to e5 with
check and here everything is still fine
black is very much ok here rock to G
with check was played King to f2 and now
comes rock to g6 and here before doing
anything
first Bishop to e5 check getting the
King to g8 King to g8 and now you don't
really want to start anything too soon
because even if you tried something like
Queenie 7 then black can always exchange
Queens with Queen to f7 check
so first our NN goes King - III getting
his King to safety and only now can he
start attacking here rook to e8 would
allow black to continue this game but
it's not all that clear why this will
allow him to play this game in the game
rook to d8 was played and this is
actually removed at that loses you the
game why it loses you the game feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
move that are on plate to win this game
I'll give it a couple of seconds for you
to decide what we want to do it or not
for those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are
excellent player 11 Arlen would be proud
and you know you might even be a
chess960 or a buck house player and for
those of you who just wanna enjoy the
show its Queen to e7 actually Queen to
e7 you only move that winds here puts
black black in sort of a tooth swung
because any move black makes now we'll
lose him the game there really isn't a
good move to make this rook here you
can't move it anywhere from from the G
file if you if you attack the Queen you
get Queen to g7 this will be checkmate
you can't move this rogue this rock has
to stay on the on the back rank because
if you move it you get rook to f8
checkmate and of course you cannot move
the Queen something like Queen to e6
because you have to protect the rock on
d8 with the Queen here in captures lose
the rook and you're getting checkmated
so there's really no good move to play
here from black and it's really you know
hard to imagine this b5 was played by
glee shock and now comes h4 h4 I'm
awesome you had to find after you found
Queen e7 because it now shows that h5 is
coming and there is very little you can
do here if black pushes h5 himself then
rook to f5 all still will be winning for
white and it's very poetic that Aragon
gets to play this beautiful combination
with a rogue sacrifice on f7 and then in
the end again play h4 his signature move
to you know bring this game to an end a5
was played the blacks position didn't
change anything you know all that much
there's really no good move black and
make h5 was played and now the rookies
challenged as you know you cannot leave
the G file Queen g7 would be checkmate
so look the g5 was played here rope to
f6 was played by Aragon and now comes
Roma captures on e5
here rook to g6 was played and it was in
this position that Alexander Grichuk
resigned the game but you know he was
really when he saw this he was come in
complete disbelief he didn't see this
broke the g6 I mean he saw the check but
he was very surprised when re unplayed
it because only move is King to h8 and
then Queen to g7 will be checkmate
so you know you're more than welcome to
check out
the video from the st. Louis live feed
it will be the first thing you will see
in the description below and if you are
one of those people who have disliked
that video you know I'm more than
welcome you to change it to alike
because like I said a chess video does
not deserve you know that amount of
dislikes nothing deserves that amount of
dislikes so yeah
a beautiful victory by LaVon Aragon and
this this victory brought and after
cousin of course won his game against
Nakamura won him first place in the
singles Cup 2018 shared first place
rather because here in Magnus Carlsen
Lebanon Yin and Fabiana Caruana shared
first place there were no playoffs and
drawing of the lots they just you know
agreed that all three of them will be
winners which is a first thing the first
time something like this has happened in
the same field Cup so that's the game a
beautiful game but level Aragon I do
hope you enjoyed it and that you enjoyed
the coverage of the single cup so far
like I said feel free to check out link
in the description below and do hit hit
that like button I would like to thank
Dom applet while it's a Bernard floor
Daniel Larson Christopher lattice and
the michael Baker for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it a lot more of you have
contributed to my channel but as I only
have room for five people per video I
will have to thank all of you in my next
video bye your name but I do thank you
in this video as well so that's pretty
much it I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check to my previous
videos your thing all for watching and I
will see you soon hopefully with some
more interesting videos and we are
continuing our Bobby Fischer series see
you soon